sound is good okay great so I wanted to
talk to you about unsupervised learning
and that's the area where there's been a
lot of research but compared to
supervised learning that you've heard
about today like convolutional networks
you know unsupervised learning is not
very yet alright so I'm going to show
you lots of lots of areas parts of the
talk are going to be a little bit more
mathematical I apologize for that but
I'll try to give you gist off of the
foundations the math behind these models
as well as try to highlight some some of
the application areas okay what's the
motivation well the motivation is that
you know the space of data that we have
today is is just growing right you know
if you look at the space of images you
know speech if you look at social
network data if you look at scientific
data I would argue that most of the data
that we see today is unlabeled right so
how can we develop statistical models
models that can discover interesting
kind of structure in unsupervised way or
semi-supervised way and that's what I'm
interested in as well as how can we sort
of apply these models across multiple
different multiple different domains and
one particular framework of doing that
is the framework of deep learning where
you're trying to learn hierarchical
representations of data and and again as
we go as I go through the talk I'm going
to show you some some examples I've
tried so here's here's one example you
know you can take a simple bag of words
representation of an article or a
newspaper you can use something that's
called an autoencoder just multiple
levels you extract some latent code and
then you get some representation out of
it right and this is done completely in
unsupervised way you don't provide any
labels and if you look at the kind of
structure that the model discovering you
know it could be useful for
visualization for example to see what's
what kind of structure you you see in
your data this was done on the on the
Reuters data set I've tried to kind of
cluster together lots of different a
supervised learning techniques and I'll
touch on some of them it's a little bit
you know it's it's not
full set but the way that I typically
think about these models is that there
is a class of what I would call non
probabilistic models you know models
like sparse coding auto-encoders
clustering based methods and these are
all very very powerful powerful
techniques and I'll cover some of them
in that talk as well and then there is
sort of a space of probabilistic models
and within probably stick models you
have tractable models you know things
like fully observed belief networks
there's a beautiful class of models
called neural auto regressive density
estimators more recently we've seen some
successes of so-called pixel recurrent
neural network models or and I'll show
you some examples of that there is a
class of so called intractable models
where you know you are looking at models
like Boltzmann machines and models like
variation water encoders something
that's been quite there's been a lot of
development in our community and deep
learning community in that space
Helmholtz machines I'll tell you a
little bit about what these models are
and a whole bunch of others as well
right one particular structure within
these models is that when you're
building these generative models or of
data you typically have to specify what
the distributions you're looking at so
you have to specify what the probability
of the data and generally doing some
kind of approximate maximum likelihood
estimation and then more recently you
know we've seen some very exciting
models coming out
these are generative adversarial
networks moment matching networks and
this is sort of a slightly different
class of models where you don't really
have to specify what the density is you
just need to be able to sample from
those models and I'm going to show you
some some examples of that okay so my
talk is going to be sort of structured
though I'd like to introduce you to the
basic building blocks models like sparse
coding models because I think that is a
very important class of models
particularly for folks who are working
in in industry and looking for simpler
models autoencoder is a beautiful class
of models and then the second part of
the talk I'll focus more on on
generative models
I'll give you an introduction on
into restricted Boltzmann machines and
deep both machines these are sort of
model statistical models that can model
so complicated complicated data and I'll
spend some time showing you some
examples some recent developments in our
community specifically in the case of
variation autoencoders which is I view
them as a subclass of Helmholtz machines
and I'll finish off by giving you an
intuition about you know a slightly
different class of models which would be
these generative adversarial networks
okay so let's let's jump into the first
part but before I do that let me just
sort of give you a little bit of
motivation and know Angie's done a great
job and Richard sort of alluded to that
as well but the idea is you know if I'm
trying to classify a particularly image
right and if I say well you know if I'm
looking specific pixel representation
might be difficult for me to classify
what I'm seeing right on the other hand
if I can find the right representations
right the right representations for
these images and then I sort of get the
right features so get the right
structure from the data that it might be
easier for me to you know see what's
what's going on with my data right so
how do I find these representations and
this is this is sort of one of
traditional approaches that we've seen
for a long time is that you know you
have a data you're creating some
features and then you run in your
learning algorithm and for the longest
time an object recognition or an audio
classification you typically use some
kind of hand design features and then
you start classifying what you have and
you know like Andre was saying in the
space of vision it's been a lot of
different features designs of what's the
right structure we should see in the
data in the space of audio same thing is
happening how can you find these right
representations for your for your data
and the idea behind their presentation
learning in particular in deep learning
is can we actually learn these
representations automatically right and
more importantly can we actually learn
these representations in unsupervised
way right by just seeing lots and lots
of unlabeled
can we achieve that and you know there's
been a lot of work done in that space
but we're not there yet so I wanted to
sort of lower your expectations as as I
show you some some of the results ok
sparse coding this is one of the models
that I think that everybody should know
what it is it was actually you know
first has its roots in 96 and it was
originally developed to explain early
visual processing in the brain sort of I
think of it as an edge detector and the
objective here is the following well if
I give you set of data points x1 up to
xn you'd want to learn a dictionary of
basis Phi 1 up to Phi K right so that
every single data point can be written
as a linear combination of the basis
that's fairly simple right there is one
constraint in that you'd want your
coefficients to be sparse you'd want
them to be mostly 0 right so every data
point is represented as a sparse linear
combination of bases right so this is if
you apply sparse coding to natural
images right and this says this was
originally it's been a lot of work
developed at Stanford with n doings
group so if you apply sparse coding to
you know take little patches of images
and it learn these bases these
dictionaries this is how they look like
and it's they look really nice in terms
of you know finding the edge edge like
structure so if you've given a new
example I can say well this new example
can be written as a linear combination
of a few of these bases right and taking
that representation it turns out that
particular representation is sparse
representation is quite useful as a
feature representation of your data
right so it's quite useful to have it
and in general helps how do we how do we
fit these models
well if I give you a whole bunch of
image patches but these don't
necessarily have to be image patches
this could be you know little speech
signals or any kind of data you're
working with you'd want to learn in a
dictionary basis you have to form you
have to solve this optimization problem
right so the first term here
you can think of it as a reconstruction
error which is to say well I take a
linear combination of my basis I want
them to match my data and that is the
second term which is you can think of it
as a sparse penalty term which
essentially says you know try to
penalize my coefficients so that most of
them are zero right that way every
single data point can be written as just
the linear combination sparse linear
combination of the basis and it turns
out there is an easy optimization for
doing that
if you fix your dictionary of bases
right by one up to five SK and you solve
for the activations that becomes a
standard lasso problem right there's a
lot of solvers for for solving that
particular problem that's a general very
you know it's it's it's a su problem
which is fairly easy to to optimize and
then if you fix the activations and you
optimized for dictionary basis then it's
a well-known quadratic programming
problem right
each problem is convex so you can sort
of alternate between finding
coefficients finding bases and so forth
so you can optimize this function and
there's been a lot of recent work in the
last ten years of doing these things
online and doing it more efficiently and
so forth right at test time given a new
input or a new image patch and given a
set of learned basis once you have your
dictionary you can then just solve a la
soupe problem to find the right
coefficients right so in this case given
a test sample or test patch you can find
well it's written by as a linear
combination of subsets of the bases
right and it turns out again that that
particular representation is very useful
particularly if you're interested in
classifying what you see in images and
this is done in completely unsupervised
way right there is no class labels there
is no specific supervisory signal that's
that's here so back in 2006 there was
work done again at Stanford that
basically showed a very interesting
result so if I give you an input like
this
and these are my learned bases remember
these little edges what happens is that
you just control
these bases you can get these different
feature Maps much like you know the
future maps that we've seen in
convolutional neural networks and then
you take these feature maps and you can
just do a classification right and this
was done on a one of the older data sets
the Caltech 101 which is sort of a data
set that predates imagenet and if you
look at you know some of the competing
algorithms if you do a simple logistic
regression versus if you do PCA and then
do logistic regression versus finding
these features using sparse coding you
can get substantial improvements right
so that's again that's that's and you
see sparks coding popping up in a lot of
different areas not just in deep
learning but folks who are using looking
at medical imaging domain in
neuroscience these are very popular
models because they're easily they're
easy to fit they're easy to to deal with
so what's the interpretation of the
sparse coding well look let's look at
this equation again and we can think of
sparse coding as finding and over
complete representation of your data
right now the encoding function we can
think of this encoding function which is
well I give you an input find me the
features or sparse coefficients or bases
that make up my image we can think of
encoding as an implicit and very
nonlinear function of X right but it's
an implicit function we don't really
specify it and the decoder or the
reconstruction is just a seem simple
linear function and it's and it's very
explicit just take your coefficients and
then multiply it by the you know find
the right basis and get back get back
the image or the data right and that
sort of flows naturally into the ideas
of autoencoders right the auto encoder
is the general framework where if I give
you an input data let's say it's an
input image you encode it you get some
representation some feature
representation and then you have a
decoder given that representation you're
decoding it back into the image so you
can think of encoding as a
as a feed-forward bottom-up pass right
much like in convolutional neural
network given the image you're doing a
forward pass and then there is also
feedback and generative or top-down pass
right given features you're
reconstructing back back the input image
in the details is what's going inside
the encoder decoder they matter a lot
and obviously you need some form of
constraints you need some of constraints
to avoid learning an identity right
because if you don't put these
constraints what you could do is just
take your input copy it to your features
and then reconstruct back right and that
would be a trivial solution so we need
to introduce some some additional
constraints if you're dealing with
binary features if you want extract
binary features for example I'm going to
show you later why you'd want to do that
you can pass your your encoder through a
sigmoid non-linearity much like in the
neural network and then you have a have
a linear decoder that we can strike back
the input and the way we optimize these
little building blocks or these little
blocks is we can just have an encoder
right which takes your input takes a
linear combination passes it through
some non-linearity the sigmoid
non-linearity or could be rectified
linear units could be 10h non-linearity
and then there is a decoder where you
reconstruct back your original input
right so this is nothing more than a
neural network with one hidden layer and
typically that hidden layer would have a
small dimensionality than the input so
we can think of it as a bottleneck layer
right and we can determine the network
parameters you know the parameters of
the encoding the parameters of the
decoder by writing down the
reconstruction error and that's what the
reconstruction would look like you know
given the input in code decode and make
sure whatever you decoding is as close
as possible to to the original to the
original input all right then we can use
back propagation algorithm to to to
Train there is an interesting sort of
relationship between all encoders and
property and principle component
analysis many of you have probably heard
about pca
as a practitioner you know if you're
dealing with large data and you want to
see what's going on
PCA is the first thing to use right much
like what you seek regression
so and the idea here is that if the
parameters of encoder and decoder are
shared and you actually have the hidden
layer which is a linear layer so you
don't use any nonlinearities then it
turns out that the space the latent
space that the model will discover is
going to be the same space as the space
discovered by PCA it effectively will
collapse the principal component
analysis right you're doing PCA which is
sort of a nice connection because it
basically says that all encoders you can
think of them as nonlinear extensions of
PCA all right so you can learn a little
richer features if if you are using
autoencoders okay so here's another
model if you're dealing with binary
input sometimes we're dealing with like
Amnesty for example again your encoder
and decoder could use sigmoid
nonlinearities so given an input you
extract some binary features binary
features you reconstruct back the binary
input and that's actually you know
relates to a model called restricted
both machines something that I'm going
to tell you about later in the talk okay
there is also other classes of models
where you can say well I can also
introduce some sparsity much like in
sparse coding to say that you know I
need to constrain my latent features on
my latent space to be sparse and that
actually allows you to learn quite
reasonable features nice features here's
one particular model called predict
expires decomposition where you
effectively you know if you look at the
first part of the equation here the
decoder part that pretty much looks like
a sparse coding model right but in
addition you have an encoding part that
essentially says train an encoder such
that it actually approximates what my
latent code should be right so
effectively you can think of this model
is that is in coder there is a decoder
but then you put the sparsity constraint
on your latent representation and you
can optimize for for that model and
obviously the other thing that we've
been doing in the last you know seven
eight and ten years is well what you can
do is you can actually stack these
things together right so you can learn
low-level features
try to learn high-level features and so
forth so just building these blocks and
perhaps at the top level if you try to
solve a classification problem you can
do that or and this is sometimes known
as a greedy greedy lair wise learning
and this is sometimes useful whenever
you have lots and lots of unlabeled data
and when you have a little label data
right a small sample of label data
typically these models help you find
meaningful representations such that you
don't need a lot of label data to solve
the particular task that you're trying
to solve right and this is again you can
remove the decoding part and then you
end up with a standard or convolutional
architecture again your encoder and
decoder could use could be convolutional
and it's it depends on what problem you
tackling and typically you know you can
stack these things together and optimize
for particular tasks that you're trying
to solve okay here's an example of just
wanted to show you some examples some
early examples back in 2006 this was a
way of trying to build these nonlinear
autoencoders and you can sort of pre
train these models using restricted
Boltzmann's or auto-encoders generally
and then you know you can stitch them
together into this deep autoencoder and
back propagate through reconstruction
laws right one thing I want to point out
is that here's one particular example
you know the top row I show you real
faces the second row you're seeing faces
reconstructed from a bottleneck of of 30
dimensional real valid bottlenecks you
can think of it as just a compression
mechanism given the data high
dimensional data you're compressing it
down to 30 dimensional code and then
from that 30 dimensional code you're
reconstructing back the original data
right so if you look at the first row
this is the data the second row shows
you reconstructed data and the last row
shows you PCA solution right one thing I
want to point out is that you know the
solution here you have a much Sharpe
representation which means that it's
capturing a little bit more structure in
the data it's so kind of interesting to
see that sometimes these models tend to
how should I say they tend to regularize
your data right like for example if you
see this person with glasses removes the
glasses and that genuinely has to do
with the fact that there is only one
person with glasses so the model just
basically said that's noise get rid of
it
oh it sort of gets rid of moustaches
right like if you see this there's no
mustache right and then again that has
to do with the fact that there's enough
capacity so the model might think that
that's just a noise and you know if
you're dealing with text type of data
this was done using a Reuters data set
you have about eight hundred thousand
stories you take bag of words
representation something very simple you
can press it down to two dimensional
space and then you see what that space
looks like right and I always like to
joke that you know the model basically
discovers that European community
economic policies that just next
disasters and accidents right this is
done this was back in I think they was
collecting ninety six right I think
today is probably going to become closer
those difference but again this is just
a way typically autoencoders a way of
compression or trying to do
dimensionality reduction but we'll see
later that they don't have to be okay
there is another class of algorithm
called semantic hashing which is to say
well what if you take your data and
compress it down to binary
representation wouldn't that be nice
because if you have binary
representation you can search in the
binary space very efficiently right in
fact if you can can compress your data
down to twenty dimension 20 dimensional
binary code to to the twenty is about
four gigabytes so you can just store
everything in memory and you can look at
the you know just do memory lookups
without actually doing any search at all
right so this sort of representation
sometimes have been used successful in
computer vision where you take your
images and then you learn these binary
representations you know thirty
dimensional codes two hundred
dimensional codes and it turns out it's
very efficient to search through large
volumes of data using binary
representation so you can you know takes
a fraction of a millisecond to retrieve
images from you know a set of millions
and millions of
just and again this is also an active
area of research right now because
people are trying to figure out we have
these large databases
how can you search through them
efficiently and sort of learning a
semantic hashing function that maps your
data to the binary presentation turns
out to be quite useful okay now let's
step back a little bit and say let's now
look at generative models let's look at
probabilistic models and how different
they are and I'm going to show you some
examples of where they applicable here's
one example of a simple model trying to
learn a distribution of these
handwritten characters so we have you
know we have Sanskrit we have Arabic we
have Syria like and now we can build a
model that says well can you actually
generate me what a Sanskrit should look
like the flickering you see at the top
these are you know a neurons you can
think of them as neurons firing and what
you're seeing at the bottom is you're
seeing what the model generates what it
beliefs ask it should look like right so
in some sense when you think about
generative models you think about models
that can generate or they can sample the
distribution or they can sample the data
this is a fairly simple model we have
about 25,000 characters you know coming
from 50 different alphabets about around
the world you have about two million
parameters is one of the older models
but this is you know what the model is a
scree should look like and I think that
I've asked couple of people to say that
is that does that really look like
Sanskrit okay great
which can mean two things it can mean
that the model is red actually
generalizing or the model is overfitting
right meaning that is just memorizing
what the training data looks like and
I'm just showing you examples from the
training data we'll come back to that
point as we go through the talk here's
you know you can also do conditional
simulation you know given half of the
image can you complete the remaining
half right and more recently there's
been a lot of advances it's actually the
last couple of years for the conditional
generations and it's pretty amazing what
you can do in terms of in painting given
half of the image but the other half of
Lima should look like this is sort of a
simple
example but it does show you that it's
trying to you know be consistent with
what different strokes look like right
so why is it so difficult in the space
of so-called undirected graphical models
of Boltzmann machines the difficulty
really comes from the following fact if
I show you this image which is a 28 by
28 image it's a binary image right so
some pixels are on some pixels are off
there are 2 to the 28 by 28 possible
images so in fact there are 2 to the 784
possible configurations right and that
space is exponential so how can you
build models that figure out in the
space of characters there's only a
little tiny subspace in that space right
if you start genuinely generating you
know 200 by 200 images you know that
space is huge in the space of real
images is really really tiny right so
how do you find that space how do we
generalize to new images that's that's a
very difficult question in general to to
answer one class of models is so-called
fully observed models right there's sort
of been a stream of learning generative
models that are tractable and they have
very nice properties like you can
compute the probabilities you can do can
do maximum likelihood estimation here's
one example where I can if I try to
model the image I can write it down as
you know taking the first pixel more
than the first pixel then modeling the
second pixel given the first pixel and
just just writing it down in terms of
conditional project of the conditional
probabilities an inch conditional
probability can take a very complicated
form right it could be a complicated
neural network and oh sorry so there's
been a number of successful models one
of the early models called neural auto
regressive density estimator actually
developed by Hugo real-valued extension
of these models and more recently we
start seeing these flavors of models
there were a couple of papers popped up
actually this year from deep mind where
they sort of make these conditionals to
be you know sophisticated RNN so STM's
or convolutional models and they can
actually generate remarkable images
and so this is just a pixel CNN
generating I guess elephants yeah and
actually looks pretty pretty interesting
right the drawback of these models is
that we yet have to see how good of
representations these models are
learning so that we could use these
representations for other tasks like
classifying images or find similar
images and such right now let me jump
into a class of models called restricted
Boltzmann so this is the class of models
where we're actually trying to learn
some latent structures some latent
representation these models belong to
the class of so-called graphical models
and graphical models very powerful
framework for representing dependency
structure between random variables this
is an example where we have you can
think of this particular model you have
some pixels this is stochastic binary so
called visible variables you can think
of pixels in your image and you have
stochastic binary hidden variables you
can think of them as feature detectors
so detecting certain patterns that you
see in the data
much like sparse coding models she has a
bipartite structure you can write down
the probability the Joint Distribution
over all of these variables you sort of
have pairwise term you have Union return
but it's not really important what they
look like the important thing here is
that if I look at this conditional
probability of the data given given the
features I can actually write down
explicitly what it looks like and what
does that mean that basically means that
if you tell me what features you see in
the image I can generate the data for
you right I can generate the
corresponding input in terms of learning
features so what do these models learn
they stop learn something similar that
we've seen in sparse coding right it's
and so these classes of models are very
similar to each other so given a new
image I can say well this new image is
made up by some combination of these
learned weights of these learned bases
and the numbers here are given by the
probabilities that each particular edge
is present in the data in terms of how
we learn these models one thing I want
to make another point I should make here
is that given an input I can actually
quickly infer what
teachers I'm seeing in the image so that
operation is very easy to do unlike in
sparse coding models it's it's a bit
more closer to Northern Quarter given
the data I can actually tell you what
features are present in my in my input
which is very important for things like
information retrieval or classifying
images because you need to do it you
need to do it fast how do we learn these
models let me just give you an intuition
maybe a little bit of math behind how we
learn these models if I give you set of
training examples and I want to learn
model parameters I can maximize the
log-likelihood objective right and
you've probably seen that in these
tutorials max and while objective is
essentially nothing more than saying I
want to make sure that the probability
of observing these images is as high as
possible right so finally the parameters
of the probability of observing what I'm
seeing is high and that's why you're
maximizing the the likelihood objective
or the log of the likelihood objection
would just you know take a product into
the sum you take the derivative there's
a little bit of algebra I promise you
it's not it's not very difficult like
you know second-year college algebra you
differentiate and you basically have
this learning rule which is the
difference between two terms the first
term you can think of it as looking at
sufficient statistic so cost official
statistics driven by the data and the
second term is the sufficient statistics
driven by the model right maybe I can
parse it out what does that mean
intuitively what that means is that you
look at the correlations you see in the
data
right and then you look at the
correlations that the model is telling
you it should be and you're trying to
match the two that's what the learning
is trying to do right it's trying to
match the correlations that you see in
the data right so the model is actually
respecting the statistics that you see
in the data but it turns out that the
second term is very difficult to compute
and it's precisely because the space of
all possible images is so high
dimensional that you need to figure out
or use some kind of approximate learning
algorithms to do that
all right so you have these difference
between these two terms the first term
is easy to compute it turns out because
of a particular structure of the model
right and we can actually do it do it
explicitly the second term is the
difficult difficult one to compute right
so it sort of requires you know summing
over all possible configurations all
possible images that that that you could
possibly see so it's this term is
intractable and what a lot of different
algorithms are doing and we'll see that
over and over again is using so-called
Monte Carlo sampling or Markov chain
Monte Carlo sampling a Monte Carlo
estimation right so let me give you an
intuition what what this term is doing
that's a general trick for you know
approximating exponential sums right the
whole subfield in in statistics that's
basically dedicated to how do we
approximate exponential sums in fact if
you could do that if you could solve
that problem you could solve a lot of
problems in machine learning and the
idea is very simple actually the idea is
to say well you're going to be replacing
the average by sampling and there's
something that's called a Gibbs sampling
Markov chain Monte Carlo which is
essentially does something very simple
it basically says well start with a data
sample the states of the latent
variables you know sample the data
sample the states of the way through
then sample the data from these
conditional distributions something that
you can compute explicitly right and
that's a general trick you know much
like in sparse coding we you know we're
optimizing for the basis when we're
optimizing for the coefficients here
you're inferring the coefficients then
you you know in vary what the data
should look like and so forth and then
you can just run a Markov chain and sort
of approximate approximate you know this
exponential sum so you start with the
data you sample the states of the hidden
variables you resample the data and so
forth and the only problem with a lot of
these methods is that you know you need
to run them up to infinity to guarantee
that you're sort of getting the right
thing and so obviously you know you will
never run them you know infinite you
don't have time to do that so there's a
very clever algorithm that contrastive
divergence algorithm that was developed
by Hinton back in 2002 and it was very
clever it basically said well instead of
this thing up to infinity run it for one
step right and so you're just running it
for one step you start with a training
vector you you update the hidden units
you update all the visible units again
so that's your reconstruction much like
an autoencoder you reconstruct your data
you update the hidden units again and
then you just update the model parameter
which is just looking at you know
empirically the statistics between the
data and the model right very similar to
what the auto encoder is doing but
slight slight differences and
implementation is basically takes about
like penalize of MATLAB code I suspect
is going to be you know two lines
intensive flow although I don't think
terms of flow folks implemented
Boltzmann machines yet that would be my
request but you can extend these models
to dealing with real valued data right
so whenever you're dealing with images
for example and it's just a little
change to the definition of the model
and your conditional probabilities hedge
is going to be bunch of gaussians so
that basically means that given the
features sample me the space of images
and i can sample you give you you know
real real valued images the structure of
the model remains the same if you train
this model on you know the these images
you sort of tend to find edges something
similar again to what you'd see in
sparse coding and I see in depending
upon analysis model auto-encoders and
such and again you can sort of say well
every single image is made up by some
some linear combination of these basis
functions you can also extend these
models to dealing with count data right
if you're dealing with documents in this
case again it's slight change to the
model K here denotes your vocabulary
size and DK the knots number of words
that you're seeing in your document
right so if you you know it's it's a bag
of words representation and the
conditional here is given by so called
softmax distribution much like what
you've seen in in the previous classes
when we you know the distribution of
possible words right and the parameters
here double use you can think of them as
you know something similar to as what
the back embedding would do and so if
you apply to in again some some of
datasets you know you tend to find
reasonable features right so can to find
you know features about Russia about us
about computers and so forth right so
much like you found these
representations little edges every image
is made up by some combination of these
edges in case of documents or webpages
you're saying the same thing it's just
made up cyma linear combination of of
these learned topics every single
document is made up by some combination
of these topics right you can also look
at one-step reconstruction so you can
basically say well how can I find
similarity between the words so if I
show you chocolate cake and further
states of hidden units and then I
reconstruct back the distribution of
possible words you know it tells me you
know chocolate cake cake chocolate sweet
dessert cupcake food sugar and so forth
right I particularly like the one about
the flour hi and then there is a
Japanese sign the model sort of
generates flour Japan Sakura blossom
Tokyo all right so it sort of picks up
again on low-level correlations that you
see in your data you can also apply
these kinds of models to collaborative
filtering where every single observed
variable you can model you know can
represent a user rating for a particular
movie right so every single user would
rate a certain subset of movies and so
you can represent it as the state of
visible via your hidden states can
represent user preferences what they are
and on the netflix data set if you look
at the latent space that the model is
learning you know some of these hidden
variables are capturing specific movie
genre right so for example there is this
is actually one hidden union dedicated
to michael michael moore's movies rights
instead of like very strong i think it's
sort of you know either people like it
or hate it so there are a few hidden
specifically dedicated to that but it
also finds interesting things like you
know action movies and so forth right so
it finds that particular structure in
the data so you can model different
kinds of modality real-valued data can
model count data
a multinomial x' and it's very easy to
infer the states of the hidden variables
so that's given just the product off of
logistic functions and that's very
important in a lot of different
applications given the input that can
quickly tell you what topics I see in
the data right one thing that I want to
point out that's an important point is a
lot of these models can be viewed as
product models sometimes people call
them product of experts and this is
because of the following the following
intuition if I write down the Joint
Distribution of my hidden observed
variables I can write it down in this
sort of log-linear form right but if I
sum out or integrate out the states of
the hidden variables I have a bunch of
product of a whole bunch of functions
right so what is what does it mean what
what's the intuition here so let me show
you an example suppose the model finds
these specific topics right and suppose
I'm going to be telling you that the
document contains topic government
corruption in mafia then the word silvio
berlusconi will have very high
probability right I guess does anybody
know you know everybody knows who Celia
Celia Berlusconi right he's he had like
you know he's in head of the government
he's connected to mafia he is his very
corrupt was corrupt and I guess I should
add like a bunker bunker parties here
right then it will become completely
clear what I'm talking about
but then you know one point I want to
make here is that it's it's you know you
can think of these models as a product
each hidden variable defines a
distribution over possible words over
possible topics and once you take the
intersection of these distributions you
can be very precise about what is it
that you modeling right so that's unlike
generally topic models or let Indian
education models models where you're
actually using mixture like a approach
and then typically these models do
perform far better than traditional
mixture based models and this comes to
the point of local versus global versus
distributed representations right in in
a lot of different algorithms you know
even the supervised learning algorithm
such as clustering
you typically have some your
partitioning the space and you're
finding local prototypes right and the
number of parameters for which you have
basically you know parameters for each
region the number of regions typically
grow with linearly with a number of
parameters but in models like factor
models PCA restricted Boltzmann machines
deep models you typically have
distributed representations right what's
the idea here the idea here is that if I
show you the two inputs right each
particular neuron can you know
differentiate between two parts of the
plane given the second one you know I
can partition it again given the third
hidden variable you can partition it
again so you can see that every single
neuron will be affecting lots of
different regions and that's the idea
behind distribute representations
because every single parameter is
affecting many many widgets not just the
local region and so the number of
regions grow roughly exponentially with
the number of parameters right so that's
the differences between these these two
classes of models important to know
about them now let me jump and quickly
tell you a little bit of inspiration
behind what what can we build with these
models right as we've seen with
convolutional networks the first layer
we typically learn some low-level
features like edges or you know if
you're working with the word word table
typically learn some low-level structure
and the hope is that the higher-level
features will start picking up some
higher-level structure as as you are
building and these kinds of models can
be built in completely unsupervised way
because what you're trying to do is
you're trying to model the data you try
to model the distribution of of the data
you can write down the probability
distribution for this models known as a
Boltzmann machine model you have
dependencies between hidden variables so
now introducing some extra you know some
extra layers and dependencies between
those layers and if we look at the
equation the first part of the equation
is basically the same as what we had
with restricted Boltzmann and then the
second and third part of the equation
essentially modeling dependencies
between you know the first and the
second hidden layer and the second
hidden layer third
in there right there is also a very
natural notion of bottom-up and top-down
so if I want to see what's the
probability of a particular Union being
taking value 1 it's really depend on
what's coming from below what's coming
from above so there has to be some
consensus in the model to say ah yes
what I'm seeing in the image and what my
model believes the overall structure
should be should be an agreement right
and so in this case of course in this
case hidden variables become dependent
even when you condition on on the data
so these kinds of models we'll see a lot
is you introducing more flexibility
you're introducing more structure but
then learning becomes much more
difficult right you have to deal you
know how do you influence in these
models right now let me give you an
intuition of what how can we learn this
model what's the maximum likelihood
estimator doing here well if I
differentiate this model with respect to
parameter basically run into the same
learning rule and it's the same one you
know you see whatever you're working
with undirected graphical models factor
graphs conditional random fields you
might have heard about those those ones
it really is just trying to look at the
statistics driven by the data
correlations that you see in the data
and the correlations that the model is
telling you it's seeing in the data and
you just try to match the two right
that's exactly what's happening in that
particular equation right but the first
term is no longer factorial so you know
you have to do some approximation with
these models let me give you an
intuition watch what each term is doing
so far as I have some data right and I
get to observe these characters well
what I can do is I really want to tell
the model this is real right these are
real characters so I want to put some
probability mass around them and say
these are real and then there is some
sort of a data point that looks like
this just bunch of pixels on and off and
I really want to tell my model that you
know put all the zero probability on
this this is not real right and so the
first term is exactly trying to do that
the first term is just trying to say put
the probability max where you see the
data and the second term is effectively
trying to say well look at this entire
exponential space and just say no
everything else is not real it's just
the real thing is what I'm seeing in
my data and so you can use sort of
advanced techniques for doing that it's
a class of algorithms called variational
inference it's something that's called
stochastic approximation which is Monte
Carlo based inference I'm not going to
go into these techniques but in general
you can you can train these models so
one question is how good are they all
right because a lot of proximation that
go into these models so what I'm going
to do is if you have if you haven't seen
it I'm going to show you two panels on
one panel you will see the real data or
another panel you'll see data simulated
by the model or the fake data and you
have to tell me which one is which okay
so again these are handwritten
characters coming from you know
alphabets around the world how many of
you think this is simulated and the
other part was real honestly okay some
what about the other way around I get
half and half which is great if you look
at these images a little bit more
carefully you will see the difference
right so you will see that this is
simulated and this is real right because
if you look at the real data it's much
crisper there is more diversity when
you're simulating the data it's a lot of
structure in the simulated characters
but some you know sometimes a little bit
files it isn't as much diversity right
and I've learned that trick from from my
neuroscience friends if I show you
quickly enough you won't see the
difference and and you know if you're
using these models for for for
classifying you know you can do proper
analysis which is to say given a new
character you find further states of the
latent variables hidden variables if I
classify based on that how good are they
and and they are they're you know
they're much better than some of the
existing techniques this is another
example you know trying to generate 3d
objects this is sort of a toys data sets
and later on I'll show you some you know
bigger advances that's been happening in
the last few years this was done a few
years ago you know if you look at the
space of generated samples they you know
they sort of you know you obviously you
can see the difference here's here's
paid look at this particular image right
this image looks like car with wings
don't you think
right so there's sometimes it can sort
of simulate things that are not
necessarily realistic and for some
reason it just doesn't generate donkeys
and elephants too often right but it
generates people with guns more often
like if you look at here and here and
here and that again has to do with the
fact that you know you exploring this
exponential space of possible images and
it's sometimes it's very hard to assign
the right probabilities the different
parts of the space right and then
obviously you can do things like pattern
completion so given half of the image
can you complete the remaining half so
the second one shows what the
completions look like and the last one
is what the truth is so you can do you
can do these things so where else can we
use these models these are sort of toy
examples but where else let me show you
one example where these models can
potentially succeed which is trying to
model the space of the multi model space
which is the space of you know images
and texts or you know generally if you
look at the data it's not just single
source it's a collection of different
modalities alright so how can we take
all of these modalities into account and
this is really just the idea of you know
given images and texts can you actually
find a concept that relates these two
different sources of sources of data and
there are a few challenges and that's
why you know models like generative
models sometimes probablistic models
could be useful general one of the
biggest challenge we've seen is that
typically when you're working with
images and text these are very different
modalities right if you think about
images in pixel representation they're
very dense if you're looking at text
it's typically very sparse right so it's
very difficult to learn these cross
model features from low-level
representation
perhaps a big challenge is that a lot of
times we see data that's very noisy
right sometimes it's just non-existent
giving an image there is no text or if
you look at the first image you know a
lot of the tags about is what kind of
camera was used to to describe that
particular image which doesn't really
tell us anything about the image itself
right and these are this would be the
text generated by a version of a
Boltzmann machine model sort of does you
know
samples what what
should look like and this is the the
idea again is very simple if you just
build a simple representation given
images and given text you just try to
find what the common representation is
it's very difficult to learn these cross
model features but if you actually build
a hierarchical model so you start with
representation you know you can build a
Gaussian model replicate itself max
molecule so build up that representation
then it turns out it's much more it
gives you much richer representation is
also when if a notion of bottom-up and
top-down which means that you know low
level or images or tags can effectively
effect low level representation of
images and the other way around so
information flows between images and
texts sort of gets into some stable
state and this is what you know the text
generated from images looks like some of
the examples you know a lot of them a
lot of them look reasonable but more
recently with the advances of cornets
this is probably not that surprising
here's some examples of the model that's
not quite doing the right thing right I
particularly like the second one for
some reason it sort of correlates with
Barack Obama and such and we've sort of
the features when we were using this
model we didn't have at that time sort
of image that features right now I don't
think we would be making these mistakes
but generally speaking you know what we
found in a lot of the data is that there
aren't a lot of images of animals right
which brings us to the next problem is
that if you don't see images of animals
then the mall is confused because it
sees a lot of Obama signs and these are
black and also white and and blue sort
of signs that appearing a lot you can
also do images from text given text or
tags can retrieve relevant images so you
know this is the data set itself at
about million images it's a nice nice
data set and you have you know very
noisy tags and the question is can you
actually learn some representation from
from those images one thing that I want
to highlight here is you know we've
tried you know this is 25,000 labeled
image somebody went and label what's
going on in those images what classes we
see in those images and you get some
numbers which is main average precision
but what's important here is that we
found that if we actually use
label data and we pre train these
channels separately using a million
label data points then we can actually
get some performance improvement so at
least that was a little bit of happy
sign for us to say that you know
unlabeled data can help in the
situations where you don't have a lot of
labeled examples so here was helping us
it was helping us a lot and then once
you get into this sort of
representations dealing with text and
images this is one particular thing you
can do and I think Richard pointed out
you know what happens in the space of
linguistic regularities you can do the
same thing with images just kind of fun
to do they they sometimes work they
don't work all the time but here's one
example if I take that particularly
image at the top and I say get the
representation of this image subtract
the representation of day add the night
and then find closes images you get
these images right and then you can do
some interesting things like take these
kittens and say - ball + box to get
kittens in the box right if you take
this particular image and say - box +
ball get kittens in the ball right
except for this thing that's a duck so
you know that's you can sort of get
these interesting interesting
representations of course these are all
sort of fun things to look at but they
don't really mean much because we're not
specifically optimizing for those things
right now let me spend some time also
talking about another class of models
these are known as Helmholtz machines
and variational tinker's these are the
models that have been sort of popping up
in our community in the last two years
right so what is a Helmholtz machine a
hell-house machine was developed back in
95 and it was developed by Hinton and
Peter Dayan and Brandon Frey and Radford
Neal and it has this particular
architecture you have a generative
process given some latent state you just
it's a neural net with a stochastic
neural network that generates the input
data right and then you have so-called
approximate inference step which is to
say given the data infer approximately
what the latent States
should look like right and again it was
developed in 95 there's something is
called waste sleep algorithm and it
never worked basically people just said
it just doesn't work and you know then
we started looking at restricted
boltzmann shades on both machines
because they were working a little bit
better and then two years ago people
figure out how to make them work and so
now 10 years later I'm going to show you
the trick now these models actually
working pretty well the difference
between Helmholtz machines and deep
Boltzmann chains is very subtle
they almost look identical the big
difference between the two is that in
hell most machines you have a generative
process that generates the data and you
have a separate recognition model that
tries to recognize what you see in the
data so you can think of this cue
function as a convolutional neural
network given the data tries to figure
out what the feature should look like
and then there is a generative model
given the features it generates the data
Boltzmann machine is sort of similar
class of models but it has undirected
connection so you can think of it as
generative and recognition connections
are the same so it's sort of a system
that tries to know which some
equilibrium state when you're running it
so it's a little bit the semantics is a
little bit different between these two
models so what is the variation water
encoder variational core is is a
Helmholtz machine it defines a
generative process in terms of sampling
through cascades of stochastic layers
and it's if you look at it there's just
bunch of conditional probability
distributions that you're defining so
you can generate the data so theta here
will denote the parameters of the
variation auto-encoders you have a
number of stochastic layers and sampling
from you know this conditional
probability distributions hallam you
know we're assuming that we can do it
it's a tractable it has to be tractable
but the innovation here is that every
single conditional probability can
actually be you know it can be very
complicated function in keynote you know
a nonlinear you can model nonlinear
relationships it can be a multi-lane
only a neural network deterministic
neural network right so it becomes
fairly fairly powerful he's here's an
example of I have a stochastic layer you
have a deterministic way have a
stochastic way and then you generate
generate the data right so you can
introduce these nonlinearities
into these models and this conditional
probability we didn't know the one layer
neural network right now I'll show you
some examples but maybe I can just give
you a little intuition behind what these
equations do and a lot of these kinds of
models learning is very hard to do and
there is a class of models called
variational learning and what the
variational learning is trying to do is
basically trying to do the phone but I
want to maximize the probability of the
data that I observe but I cannot do it
directly so instead what I'm going to do
is I'm going to maximize the so called
variational Lobot which is this term
here right and it's effectively saying
well if I take the log of expectation I
can take the log and push it inside
right and it turns out just logistically
working in this representation is much
easier than working in this
representation right if you go a little
bit through the math turns out that you
can actually you know optimize this
variation above but you can't really
optimize this particular likelihood
objective it's a little bit surprising
for those of you who haven't seen
variation of learning how it's done you
know but this one little check this one
little so-called Jensen's inequality
actually allows you to solve a lot of
problems right and the other way to
write the lower bound is to say well
there is a log likelihood function and
something is called KL divergence which
is the distance between your
approximating distribution Q which is
your recognition model and the truth the
truth in these models would be the true
posterior cording to your to your model
and it's hard to optimize these kinds of
models in general you know you're trying
to optimize your generative model you
try to optimize the recognition model
and back in 88 back in 95 Hinton and his
students basically they developed this
wake-sleep algorithm that was a bunch of
different things put together but it was
never quite the right algorithm because
it wasn't really optimizing anything it
was just bunch of things alternating but
in 2014 there was a beautiful trick
introduced by kingman Welling and there
was a few other groups that came up with
the same trick called recanalization
trick right so let me show you what
repolarization trick does intuitively
so let's say your recognition
distribution is a Gaussian right so a
Gaussian I can write it as you know I
mean in the variance so this is the mean
this is the variance notice that my mean
depends on the layer below could be very
nonlinear function the variance also
depends on the layer below so it could
also be a nonlinear function but what I
can do is I can actually do the
following I can express this particular
Gaussian in terms of Xillia variables so
I can say well if I sample this epsilon
from normal 0 1 a Gaussian distribution
then I can write this particular H right
my-my-my state in a deterministic way
it's just mean plus essentially standard
deviation or variance square root of the
variance times this epsilon right so
this is just a simple parameterization
of the gaussians right and just pulling
out the mean and the variance there's no
sort of surprises here so I can write my
recognition model as this Gaussian or I
can write it in terms of noise plus the
deterministic part right so the
recognition distribution can be
represented as a deterministic mapping
and that's that's the beauty because it
turns out that you can collapse these
complicated models effectively into
auto-encoders right and we know how to
deal with auto-encoders we can back
propagate through the entire through the
entire model so we have a deterministic
encoder and then the distribution of
these auxiliary variables really don't
depend on parameters right so we sort of
it's almost like taking a stochastic
system and separating the stochastic
part and deterministic part in the
terminus tic part you can do back
propagation so you can do learning and
the stochastic Park you can do sampling
right so just think of it as a
separation between the two the two
pieces so now if I take the gradient of
the variational bound or variational
objective with respect to parameters
this is something that we couldn't do
back in 95 and we couldn't do it in the
last 10 years people tried using
reinforced algorithm or some
approximations that never worked but
here what we can do is we can do the
following we can say well I can write
this expression because it's a Gaussian
a sampling bunch of these axillary
variables
and then this log I can just inject the
noise in here the whole thing here
becomes deterministic and that's that's
where the beauty comes in you take these
gradient here and you push it inside the
expectation right so before if you take
the gradient of expectation it's like
taking the gradient of averages like you
compute bunch of averages in you're
taking the gradient what you're doing
now with reprimands a ssin trick is
you're taking the gradients and then
taking the average right it turns out
that huge it reduces the variance in
your training and it actually allows you
to learn these models quite quite
efficiently so the mapping edge here is
is completely deterministic and
gradients here can be computed by back
propagation is a deterministic system
and you can think of this thing inside
it's just an autoencoder that that you
are that you are optimizing and
obviously there are other extensions of
these models that we've looked at and a
bunch of other teams looked at where you
can say well maybe we can improve these
models by drawing multiple samples these
are so-called K samples importance
weighting bounce and so if you can make
them a little bit better a little bit
more precise you can model a little bit
more complicated distributions over the
over the posterior but now let me sort
of step back a little bit and say why am
I telling you about this what's the
point there's a bunch of equations you
injecting noise why do we need noise why
do we need stochastic scene systems in
general right here's a motivating
example we wanted to build a model that
given captions we want to generate the
image right and my student was very
ambitious and basically said I want to
be able to just tell give you any
sentence and and I want to be able to
generate image like kind of like an
artificial pain I want to paint what
what's in my what's in my caption in the
most general way right so this is one
example of a Helmholtz machine where you
have a generative model which is a
stochastic recurrent network is just a
change sequence of a variational
auto-encoders and there's a recognition
model which is you can think of a
deterministic system like a
convolutional system that tries to
approximate what the latency states are
but why do I need why do I need to the
caste city here why do I need very short
encoders here and the reasons very
simple suppose I
you know I give you the following tasks
right I say a stop sign is flying in
blue skies okay
now if you were using a deterministic
system like an auto encoder you would
generate one image right because it's a
deterministic system give an input I
give you you know I'll give you output
once you have stochastic system you
inject this noise this latent noise that
allows it to actually generate a whole
space of possible images right so for
example it tends to generate like this
stop sign and this stop sign they look
very different right and there's a car
here so maybe it's not really flying is
just can't draw the pole here this one
looks like they're clouds here's this
yellow school buses flying in those guys
right so here we wanted to test the
system to see does it understand
something about what's what's in the
sentence here's a herd of elephants is
flying in blue skies now we cannot
generate elephants although there are no
techniques that are getting better but
you know sometimes it generates two of
them right and the commercial plane
flying in blue skies but this is where
we need stochastic because we want to be
able to generate the whole distribution
of possible outcomes not necessarily
just one particular point right here's
you know we can basically do things like
you know a yellow school bus parked in
the parking lot versus a red school bus
parked in the parking lot
versus a green school bus park in the
parking lots it's sort of the blue
school bus rights it's sort of we can't
quite generate blue school buses but
we've seen blue cars and we've seen blue
buses so it can sort of make an
association to to draw these different
things they look a little bit fuzzy but
you know in terms of comparing two
different models if I give you a group
of people on the beach with surfboards
this is what we can generate there is
another model called webcam model which
is a model based on that the cellular
networks something out I'll talk last
part of this talk and there is these
models convolutional deconvolution all
the ocean water encoders which is again
convolutional deconvolution 'l
auto-encoders just with with some noise
and you can certainly see that you know
it's generally we found it's very hard
to be able to generate scenes with
arbitrary inputs as a text right here's
here's my favorite one a toilet it's
it's open in the bathroom
all right I don't know if you can see a
toilet sits here maybe but you can say
toilets it's it's open in the grass
field that was a little bit better at
least the colors were quite right and
when we put this paper on archive one of
one of the students basically came to me
and said well this is really bad because
you can always ask Google right and if
you if you type that particular query
into Google search it gives you that all
right which was a little bit
disappointing but now if you actually
Google or if you actually put this query
into Google this image comes before this
image and generally because what's
happening is that people are just
clicking on that image all the time to
figure out what's going on in that image
so we got bumped up before before that
other means so so now I can say that
according to Google this is a much
better representation for that sentence
now than listen here's another here's
another sort of interesting model which
is a model where you're trying to build
a recurrent neural network again it's a
generative model but it's a generative
model of text this was this model was
trained on about 7,000 romance novels
and you take a caption model and you
hook it up to the to the caption
generation system so you're basically
saying the model here's an image
generate me you know in the style of
romantic books what what you'd see here
and you know it generates generates
something interesting we barely were
able to catch the breeze on the beach
and so forth she's beautiful but the
truth is I don't know what to do the Sun
was just starting to fade away leaving
people scattered around the Atlantic
Ocean so and there are a bunch of
different things that you can do
obviously you know we're not there yet
in terms of generating romantic stories
but here's a one example where it's a
generative model it seems like
syntactically we can actually generate
you know reasonable things semantically
we're not there yet right and actually
that particular work was inspired a
little bit by by actually by by deuce
system that would give
image it would I think of generate poems
right but the points were predefined so
it was mostly the selecting the right
point for the image here we actually
were trying to you know generate
something something so there's still a
lot of work to do in that space because
you know syntactically we can get there
semantically we are nowhere near you
know getting getting the right structure
here is another last example that I want
to show you this was done in the case of
one shot warning which is can you build
generative model of characters right
that's a very defined domain very well
defined domain it's a very simple domain
but it's also very hard right here's one
example we've shown this example to
people and to the algorithm and we can
say well can you draw me this this
example and you know on one panel humans
would draw you know how they believe
these this example should look like and
then on the other panel we have machines
drawing it right this is it really just
a generative model of based on a single
example showing you example and try to
generate what it is and so question for
you how many of you think this was a
machine generated and this was human
generated ah what about the other way
around more MORE aha so there is a vote
what this is what about this one this is
the how many do you think this machine
generated is a human generated a few
what about that aware it around ah great
great well the truth is I don't really
know which one was genuine about this
machine because that was done I should
actually ask Brandon Lake who designed
the experiments for this particular
model but I can tell you that I can tell
you that you know there's been a lot of
studies he's done a lot of studies and
it's about you know it's almost 50/50 so
in sort of this kind of small carve
domain we can actually compete with
people you know trying to generate these
these characters now let me step back a
little bit and tell you about a
different class of models these are
models known as generative adversarial
networks and they've been gaining a lot
of attraction in in our community
because they seem to produce remarkable
results
so here's here's the idea we're not
going to be really defining explicitly
the density but we need to be able to
sample from the model right and the
interesting thing is that there's no
variation learning there is no maximum
likelihood estimation there is no Markov
chain Monte Carlo there's no sampling
how do you do that how do you learn
these models and it turns out that you
can learn these models by playing a game
and that's a very clever strategy and
the idea is the following you're going
to be setting up a game between two
players you're going to have a
discriminator do you think of it as a
convolutional network convolutional
neural network and then you're going to
have a generator gee maybe you can think
of it as as a variational tank or a
Helmholtz machine or something that
gives you samples from the data the
discriminated D is going to be
discriminating between a sample from the
data distribution and a sample from the
generator so the goal of the
discriminate is to is to basically say
is this a fake sample or is this a real
sample right fake sample the sample
generated by the model real sample is
what you see in your data right can you
tell the difference between the two
right and the generator is going to be
trying to fool the discriminator by
trying to generate samples that are hard
for discriminator to discriminate so my
goal is a generator would be to generate
really nice-looking digits so that the
discriminator won't be able to tell the
difference between you know simulate it
and the real right that's the key idea
and so here is intuitively what what
that looks like let's say you have you
have some data so images of faces give
you an image your face and now I have a
discriminated basically Tazewell if I
get a real face I push it through some
function some differentiable function
think of it as a convolutional neural
network or another differentiable
function and here I'm outputting one
right so I want to output one if it's a
real sample right then you have a
generator right and generator is you
have some noise so input noise think of
it as a Gaussian distribution thinking
about Helmholtz machines given some
noise I go through differentiable
function which is your generator and
January's sample this is my design my
sample might look like right and then on
top of it I take this sample I put it
into my discriminator and I say for my
discriminator I want to output 0 right
because my discriminator will have to
say well this is fake and this is real
right that's the goal and the generator
basically says well how can I get a
sample such that my discriminate is
going to be confused such that the
discriminator always outputs 1 here
right because it believes it's a true
sample believe is it coming from the
truth data right so now you have these
systems so what's what's the objective
the objective is a min Max value
function it's a very intuitive objective
function that has the following
structure you have a discriminator that
says well this is an expectation with
respect to distribution data
distribution so this is basically saying
I want to classify any data points that
I get from my data as being real right
so I want this output to be 1 because if
it's 1 the whole thing is going to be 0
if it's less than 1 it's going to be
negative and I really want to maximize
it and then discriminator says well any
time I generate a sample whatever
samples comes out from my generator you
know I want to classify it as being fake
right that's the goal of the
discriminator and then there is a
generator the generator is sort of the
other you know you try to minimize this
function which essentially says well
generate samples that discriminate it
would classify as real so I really want
to try to imagine you know change the
parameters of my generator such that
this would produce 0 right so also so
the discriminant would produce 1 right
so trying to full full the discriminator
right and it turns out the optimal
strategy for discriminate is this this
ratio which is probability of the data
divided probability of the data by plus
probability of the model and in general
if you succeed in building a good
generative model then probability of the
data would be the same as probability of
the models so discriminator will always
be confused still 1/2
right and here's one particular it seems
like a simple idea but it turns out that
work remarkably well here's an
architecture called D convolutional
generative adversarial network
architecture that takes the code this is
a random code it's a Gaussian code it
passes through a sequence of
convolutions also a sequence of
deconvolution so given the code you sort
of deconvolve it back to high
dimensional image and you train it using
at the settle setting right this is your
sampling you generate the image and then
there is a discriminator which is just a
convolutional neural net what is trying
to say is that the real is that a fake
and if you train these models on
bedrooms these are called L some data
sets a bunch of bedrooms this is how
samples from the model would look like
which is pretty impressive
in fact when I look at these samples I'm
also sort of maybe the models memorizing
the data because these samples look
remarkably impressive then there was a
follow-up work these are samples from
the CFR data set so here you seeing
training samples and here you're seeing
samples generated from the model which
is again very impressive if you look at
the structure in these samples it's
quite remarkable that you can generate
you know samples that look very
realistic actually this is what's done
again this was done by team team Shannon
and his collaborators if you look at the
image net and you look at the training
data on the image net and looking at the
samples again you look live the horse
this is like there is some animal there
is an airplane and so forth is like some
kind of a truck and such right so it
looks you know when I look at these
images and I was very impressed by the
quality of these image because Jo is
very very hard to generate realistic
looking images and the last thing I want
to point out this was picked up by Ian
good fellow if we cherry pick some of
the examples this is what generated
images look like alright so you can sort
of like see there is a little bit of
interesting structure that you're seeing
in these samples right and one question
still remains with these models is how
can we evaluate these models properly
right is the model really learning a
space of all possible images and how
images what's the coherency in those
images or is the model mostly kind of
like blurring things around and just
making some small changes to the data so
the question that I would really want
would like to answer to be you know to
get an answer to is that if I showing
you a new example a new test image a new
kind of a horse would the model say yes
this is this is a likely image this is
this is very probable images I've seen
you know similar images before or
something like that or not so that still
remains an open question but again this
is the class of models which steps away
from maximum likelihood estimations sort
of sets it up in the game theoretic
framework which is which is a really
nice set of work and in computer vision
community a lot of people are shown a
lot of progress and using these kinds of
models because they tend to generate
much more realistic looking images so
let me just summarize to say that you
know I've shown you hopefully a set of
learning algorithms for deep
unsupervised models you know there's a
lot of space in these models a lot of
excitement in that space and just wanted
to point out that these models the deep
models they improve upon current state
of the art and a lot of different
application domains and as I mentioned
before there's been a lot of progress in
discriminative models convolutional
models using recurrent neural networks
for solving you know action recognition
models dealing with videos and
unsupervised learning it still remains
sort of a field where we've made some
progress but there's still a lot of
progress to be made and let me let me
stop there so thank you
do the mics oh sorry so as a Bayesian
guy I'm pretty depressed by the fact
that can can generate clearer image than
the variational in total encoder so my
question is do you think there could be
a energy based framework or
probabilistic interpretation of why
again is so successful other than it's
just a me max game I think that
generally you know if you look at I sort
of go back and forth between variational
- encoders because you know some of my
friends at Open AI saying that they can
actually generate really nice-looking
images using variational encoders I'm
looking at Peter here but you know what
I think that one of the problems with
image generation today is that with
variation autoencoders there is this
notion of Gaussian loss function right
and what it does is it basically says
well never produce you know
crystal-clear images because if you're
wrong if you put at the edge in the
wrong place you're going to be penalized
a lot because of the l2 loss function
right what the gans are doing ganz are
basically saying well I don't really
care where I put the edge as long as it
looks realistic so that I can fool my
classifier so what tends to happen in
practice and a lot of times if you
actually look at the images generated by
Ganz sometimes they have a lot of
artifacts like you know these specific
things that that pop up right whereas in
variation think odors you don't see that
but again the problem variational
thinker is they tend to produce images
that are much more diffused or you know
not as short or not as clear as what
ganz is doing and there's been some work
on you know trying to sharpen the images
which is using variational encoders to
generate you the globally coherent scene
and then you're using generative slls to
maybe sharpen it again it's it's it
depends what loss function you're using
and again seem to be able to deal with
that problem implicitly right because
they don't really care whether
you get the edge quite right or not as
long as its Falls your classifier thank
you hi thank you very much for the
interesting talk I have a question about
the evaporation auto-encoder for the
Marshall engine data set like the Street
View house number I noticed that many
implementation they use a PCA to
pre-process the data before the trainer
model why is your thought on that pea
processing step why is necessary to do
that
right why don't we just learn from the
raw pixel I actually don't know my
experience has been that we don't really
do a lot of pre-processing I mean what
you can do is you can do CCA
pre-processing is you can take the mean
you can take the sort of the
second-order covariance structure from
the data that sometimes helps sometimes
it doesn't but I don't see any
particular reason why you'd want to do
PCA Prasad pre-processing right I mean
it's just one of just like you know
we've seen a lot in our field people
just doing X Y and then later on they
figure out that they don't really need x
and y right so it's maybe it was working
better for their implementation for
their particular task but generally I
haven't seen people doing a lot of
pre-processing using PCA for training
you know variational - encoders
any more question yes there's one where
is regarding binary rbms so if you look
at the literature for let us say
estimation of the partition function for
easing models right you will see that
the literature is lot more rich compared
to the variational inference literature
for restricted Boltzmann machines
especially in the binary context is
there like a cultural reason for this
because specifically you know like you
have for the strictly ferromagnetic case
you have a fully polynomial time
approximation scheme for estimating the
log partition function right so but then
I don't see usage of these F press kind
of algorithms in the RBM space so when
you kind of juxtapose with the
literature for the easing models
compared to binary rpms you'll find like
a very stark asymmetry is there like a
reason for this yeah so they think the
thing about easing models is that you
know here like in ferromagnetic case or
if you are you know you have certain
particular structure to the easing
models you can use a lot of techniques
like even if use techniques like
coupling from the paths you can draw
exact samples from the models right you
can compute the log partition function
the polynomial convey a specific
structure they think about rbms is that
generally those assumptions don't apply
like you cannot learn them all which is
this ferromagnetic model with RBA it's
just way all your weights are positive
right that's a lot of constraints to put
on on these class of models so that's
why you know and once you get outside of
these assumptions then the problem
becomes np-hard right for estimating the
partition function and obviously for
learning these systems you need the
gradient of the log of the partition
function right and that's where all the
problems come in I don't think there is
there is a solution for that and
unfortunately variational methods are
also not working as well as you know
approximations like contrastive
divergence or something based on based
on sampling people have looked at better
approximations and using sort of more
sophisticated techniques but it's it
hasn't it hasn't really popped up yet
practically it just doesn't work as well
but it's a good question no my question
is about using auto coder with a to get
semantic hash
especially in text do we need to any
special representation text text
representation like word to vector as
input for the for our text sequence so
you know I've talked about them all
which is very simple knowledge is
modeling bag of words yes right
obviously you can take word to Veck and
initialize the model right because it's
a way of just taking your words and
projecting them into the semantic space
yeah right there is been a lot of
technique recent techniques using like
richard was mentioning gr use as a way
you know if you want if you want to work
with sentences or if you want to embed
the entire document into the semantic
space if you want to make it binary you
know you can use gr use bi-directional
gr use sort of get the representation of
the document I think that would probably
work better than using word to back and
then just adding things up and then
based on that you can learn a hashing
function that map's that particular
representation to the binary space right
in which case you can you can do
searching fairly efficiently so as an
input representation a lots of choices
you can use bi-directional gr use which
is the you know the the the the method
of choice right now you can use glove or
you can use work the rack can be you
know some them sum up the
representations of the words okay so
using only back of word we use only
normal needs work
neural network that is no records which
were or yeah yeah that's right that's
simple it's just right but again
you're doing your representation can be
whatever that representation is as long
as differentiable right okay so in this
case you can you can sort of back
propagate through the bi-directional gr
use and get rip you know learn what
there is what this game isn't a Shashank
you so much okay let's thank Russ again